- Nous sommes dans le quartier
Notre-Dame à proximité
de la Fonderie Horne.
Une récente étude ici a démontré
que les enfants du quartier
ont quatre fois plus d'arsenic
dans le corps en moyenne
qu'ailleurs au Québec.
L'indice du cancer du poumon
à Rouyn-Noranda est aussi
significativement plus élevé.
C'est dans ce contexte que
Glencore, propriétaire
de l'entreprise, négocie avec
le gouvernement afin de diminuer
ses émissions d'arsenic
notamment. La fonderie propose
une moyenne annuelle de
60 nanogrammes par mètre cube.b.
La norme québécoise, elle,
est de 3; c'est donc 20 fois
la norme québécoise.
Cette mère de famille
n'en revient pas.
VALÉRIE FOURNIER, porte-parole
du Comité Arrêt
- Il ne devrait pas y avoir
de négociations, ça devrait
être le gouvernement qui fixe
le chiffre, qui fixe
l'échéancier et l'entreprise
doit s'yer un point
c'est tout. Là, on a
l'impression qu'on achète
du temps. Les citoyens sont
impatients, sont inquiets,
la situation elle est urgente.
- C'est difficile de présumer
de la bonne foi d'une entrep
qui agi comme ça.
- Ce médecin de famille
à Rouyn-Noranda estime,
pour sa part, qu'il ne s'agit
même pas d'une base
de négociation.
FRÉDÉRIC BONIN, médecin de
famille à Rouyn-Noranda
- Faut vraiment qu'on aille
beaucoup plus loin que ça.
On le sait qu'on paye le poids
du passé au niveau de notre
santé. Là, c'est le temps
de prendre de bonnes décisions
pour le futur.
- En 2021, la Fonderie Horne
a émis en moyenne 87 nanogrammes
par mètre cube.
Lors de négociations avec
le gouvernement Charest en 2006,
l'entreprise assurait pouvoir
atteindre 39 nanogrammes
par mètre cube à condition
d'investir 120 millions $.
Mais Québec avait par la suite
reculé devant les pressions
de l'entreprise et fixé
la limite à 200 ne à 200 ne à 2.
- De voir que l'entreprise
proposer quelque chose de plus
haut qu'elle a déjà proposé,
c'est presque irréel.
SE LESSARD-THERRIEN,
députée QS Rouyn-Noranda/Témis.
- À l'heure actuelle,
ce qu'on voit, c'est que
les gouvernements qui se sontsue
de laxisme, se sont couchés
devant l'entreprise.
DOMINIQUE ANGLADE, cheffe
du Parti libéral du Québec
- Oui, c'est un rendez-vous
raté, mais la réalité,
c'est que l'information n'était
pas disponible comme elle l'est
depuis 2018 et cette information
aurait dû inciter
le gouvernement à agir.
- La Fonderie Horne a refusé
de répondre à nos questions.
Elle déposera un nouveau plan
au gouvernement au cours du mois
d'août. Au cabinet du premier
ministre, on réitère que si
l'entreprise n'est pas capable
de se rapprocher de la norme
québécoise, on n'exclut pas
de fermer l'usine.
Ici Jean-Marc Belzile,
Radio-Canada, Rouyn-Noranda